من بدايه الشهر واحنا بنستعرض معكم ملخصات
وحصاد من السنه مع اقترابها من النهايه
وفقرتنا الجايه همم من هذا النوع ونجمعها
اليوم جوجل المحرك البحث الاول في العالم
واللي يعني اسمه تحول حتى لفعل اسر جوجل
بمثابه مرادف لكلمه البحث او ابحث جوجل
وما اقتراب السنه من نهايتها نشرت فيديو
في ابرز ما بحث عن الناس
مالي لكن هاعمل
هازنجاواين عارف
ين
الناس دورت عليها على جوجل جمل
كيف اغير بالاضافه انه للعفويه والعثور
على الشغف وبالنسبه للكلمات في عالميا
لعبه ورد الجديده كانت في المركز الاول
اسماء مباريات مهمه في بطوله كريكيت كانوا
ايضا في راس القائمه هذه اللعبه الشهيره
جدا في بريطانيا والهند والاسيويه اخرى
عديده اوكرانيا والملكه اليزابيث كانوا
كمان في راس القائمه لكن لو حبينا نفصل
اكثر في النتائج ونمسك مثلا الاخبار راح
نلاقيه اوكرانيا في المرتبه الاولى رحيل
الملك في المرتبه الثانيه نتائج
الانتخابات في المرتبه الثالثه المرتبه
الرابعه للي نصيب الامريكي الشهير باور
بول والخامسه عندنا الجدري القرده اما
بالنسبه للمشاهير في التاليه اسمائهم
كانوا اكثر من بحث عنهم الناس على جوجل
طبعا جوني داب في المرتبه الاولى وفي
المرتبه الثالثه طريقته بسبب المحاكمه
الشهيره بينهم في قضيه التشهير اللي
سابعها العالم كله واللي كسبها جوني ديب
في المرتبه الثانيه عندنا ويل سميث في
المرتبه الخامسه كريس روك والسبب طبعا
الصفحه الشهير اللي اكلها كريس من ولفي
حفل الاوسكار اما في المرتبه الرابعه فكان
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمر بالنسبه للرياضيين
في اول ثلاث مراتب كان في نوفاكوفيتش
ورافاييل نزال وسيرينا وليامز جدا صراحه
انه الثلاثه لاعبين تنسى لانه يعني صحيح
هم من اشهر لاعبين العالم لكن اللعبه
النخويه نوعا مقارنه يعني بلعبه كره القدم
اما بالنسبه للوفيات فاكثر الراحلين الى
الناس كانت مهتمه فيهم على جوجل في 20 22
كيلو او مثل ما هو متوقع في المرتبه
الاولى اللي رحلت عن 97 السنه بعد 70 سنه
حكم في المرتبه الثانيه الممثله باتي وايت
اللي رحلت في 31 ديسمبر 20 21 عن 99 عاما
وراها انهيس اللي قضت في حادث سير كانت
سارقه فيه واتضح انها كانت تحت تاثير
مخدرات وهي بتسوق وبعدها بوب سقط نجم في
الهاوس اللي توفى بشكل مفاجئ في نوم وفي
يناير والفنان ارين كارتر اللي توفي من كم
اسبوع وهو شقيق النجم فرقه
من النتائج العالميه الى النتائج المحليه
خلونا نبدا سوا ونشوف اكثر كلمات ان اعمل
عنها في جوجل في السعوديه ومصر في 20 22
[موسيقى]
بسم الله
اما بالنسبه للشخصيات في اكثر من تصدر
وجوجل في السعوديه ومصر هم هذه القائمه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
واخيرا تعبان روح عالم الموسيقى ونشوف
اكثر الاغاني اللي تصدرت جوجل
[موسيقى]
نفسي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ويندم الينا في الاستوديو رئيس تسويق
المنتجات الاستهلاكيه في جوجل الشرق
الاوسط الشمال افريقيا نجيب جرار اهلا فيك
معنا نجيب
اهلا شكرا لاستضافتكم اليك منورنا اليوم
وهذه المعلومات يعني بصراحه خليني اقول لك
في كثير منها يعني متوقع مثلا مثل الملكه
اليسب ثم الى ذلك في اشياء ثانيه بتفاجا
الواحد يعني شويه بس انتم اصلا عندكم كم
كبير من المعلومات كيف يتم حصرها ودراستها
عشان تطلعوا بهذه القوائم طبعا هاي
القوائم اللي احنا بنعملها كل سنه خلال
على السنين ال 12 لبعض يعني وهي منحاول
نفرجي ايش الاتجاهات او ايش الاشياء اللي
الناس بحث عنها اكثر شيء همم خلال السنه
الماضيه في كل دوله من انحاء العالم
ومنطلع منحاول نشوف ايش الاشياء الجديده
اللي طلعت هذه السنه يعني خاصه ضد النظر
عن الاشياء اللي كان متوقع مثل همم
وهذه بيفرجي اتجاهات ايش الاشياء اللي
حصلت من الاخبار او الاشياء لها مثال كويس
على هذا شفنا مثلا اهتمام الجديده هذه
السنه وكان بشكل اكبر على فرق همم تحويل
العمله ما بين الجنيه المصري الدولار
الامريكي
طبعا بنتيجه اللي هو انخفاض سعر تحويل
العمله في مصر همم فبالتالي
المواطن همم المواطنين في مصر طروا انهم
يروحوا يفتشوا حتى يعرفوا الاسعار
ولاحظ كمان في الفيديو اللي انتم عاملينه
همم او تعرف كل سنه عن سنه بيلاحظ بزياده
الاهتمام يمكن بموضوع الصحه النفسيه او
كيف انه زي ما انتم بتقولوا انه اغير او
اعثر على الشغف او اكون حياتي مثلا
تلقائيا اكثر او هذا هل برده بتلاحظوا هذا
الترند ماشي طبعا همم هذا الشيء شفناه
قاعد بيزيد وواتيرته بعد همم
حوالي اكثر من 65% من الاشخاص في الوطن
العربي سواء كان في مصر في الامارات في
السعوديه الى اخره بحثوا على انهم كيف
يتعلموا مهنه جديده حتى يطوروا ويناموا من
حالهم كمان بشكل اكبر حتى ادمن فيرجي همم
النساء على الانترنت قاعدين بيفتشو كيف هم
يكونوا يتعلموا مهنه شديده او انه لا شغل
همم عن طريق الانترنت همم كمان همم هذا
طبعا سوف نتيجه اهتمام الويل الناس على
الصحه النفسيه بعد خلال فتره ال- ال-
الكوبد والحجز اللي كان قاعد بصفه
قلق نوبات هلا على كل هذه الكلمات همم
يعني صار عليها بحث بزياده اعتقد خلال
فتره كوفد وما بعدكم بس انتم بتسووا هذه
الاشياء بطريقه يعني هل عندكم انه كده
مثلا جهاز بيحسب الامور ولا كيف بتصير همم
عندنا همم العديد من الخوارزميات اللي
بتحاول تجمع ايش هي عمليات البحث
المتشابهه من اكثر من مكان ومن حولنا نشوف
ايش هي العمليات اللي بتطلع طبعا هذا احنا
بنعملها حتى نحسن وجود البحث لما نشوف
المزيد من المواطنين مثلا سعر تحويل
العمله من الجنيه للدولار بنحاول نشوف كيف
نقدر نجاوبهم بشكل اسرع
وهذا طبعا بيساعدنا نتجاوب بشكل همم
بتصير في هذه الدول ياخذني النقطه اللي هو
انتم كنتم تكلمتوا عنا سابقا انكم
بتحاولوا ترفعوا من جوده السيرج العربي
عشان يصير همم جوده التركي بالانجليزي كيف
صار معكم هذا الموضوع اول وصلتوا فيه طبعا
احنا بنعمل تحديثات دوريه على جوده الخدمه
تبعتنا وهمم واسرعنا من وتيره هذه
التحديات خلال السنين الاربعه والخمسه
الماضيه همم واحده من اجمل همم الاشياء
الجديده اللي هو انت هلا بتقدر باستخدام
عدسه جوجل عدسه جوجل عن طريق تطبيق جوجل
بتصوري او اي شيء او بت- بتفتح الكاميرا
عليها تتعرف على هو هذا وبتفرجيكي منتجات
مثله بتفرجيك النتيجه هلا بدنا احنا نعرف
اشياء الخطوه اللي بعدها مثلا اذا انت
معاش صورت همم لبس عاجبك نفطر بنطلون او
شيء معين او كان لونها اسود مباشره انت
لما تحكي بس بالابيض اه جوجل تعرف انت
اللون همم بدك مثل هذه اللبسه اللي موجوده
نفتش لك وين الاماكن اللي قريبه منك اللي
بتفتش عادي اللبسه ونجيب لك المعلومات
بشكل اوضح وهذا نفهم مش بس بالضبط همم
الطلب تبعك بس حتى اللغه والخصائص والموقع
الجغرافي تبعك في المنطقه العربيه كمان
رائع لو جوجل بس يتحول لانسان ويصير ماشي
معي طول الوقت بيساوي لك اولاد الاشياء ان
شاء الله هدفنا في جوجل يكون همم موجودين
لما اي حد يحتاج اي مساعده في اي موجود من
المعلومات ممكن ناس تطلب منه
ان شاء الله تخيلت كده واحد ماشي جنبي همم
بتتحكموا في تجيب نقول ثاني السوق البحث
او انتم همم المحرك الاول في البحث همم
همم
بالضبط محرك
تحت جديد في المنافسه لانه الان كل
الدراسات بتشير الى انه مثل منصات مثل تيك
توك الناس بتدخل عليهم وبتستعملهم كمحركات
بحث ايضا امم زي ما انا حكيت لك احنا
غالبا نركز على قدرتنا احنا نفسنا نحاول
نطور من منتجاتنا ناخذ ايش الاشياء
الجديده المستخدمين بفضلوها ويحاول نخلي
التشربه طبقتهم احسن المعلومات عندنا احدث
واسرع في نفس الوقت وبالعكس كل ما يكون في
المنافسه في السوق او في المنطقه معينه من
منتجات بيكون احسن لانه هذا بيشجع همم
لتوفير همم تجربه استخدام احسن للمستخدم
في الاخر كل ما عندك ناس بتتنافس الفائز
الوحيد هو المستخدم هذا هو شيء في الصوت
طبعا بس انتم يعني بتحرسوا على المقدمه
كمان في النهايه نتاكد انه احنا همم
اجهزه اي اي سؤال عنده
عن طريق ان احنا نكون عندنا احدث واحسن
واسرع الاجوبه اللي هم ممكن يحتاجوها
احنا بنشكرك على هذه اليوم المشاركه
والمعلومات هذه عن ايش بحثوا الناس او ايش
كانت اهتماماتهم في 20 22 لما الواحد
بيرجع بيطالع فيها بيشوف قديش كانت السنه
مليانه بالاشياء والاهتمامات المختلفه
[موسيقى]